[Music]
the best piece of advice i ever ever got
was shut the [ __ ] up and listen
that was the best advice i got be in
comics we talk for a living
and we're always running our mouths
listen and you will learn so much
because obviously if you're in a uh
circle with some og's there
you definitely don't know as much as
they are and even if you disagree or
think you don't always have to verbalize
that
shut the [ __ ] up and listen the best
advice that i i got and that i can give
do you want me to turn it the other way
or keep it like this way
um it's whatever you're comfortable with
i like it like this
well then yeah let's let's do it the way
you like
that's what we like what every woman
what every woman wants to hear
so thank you all right honestly thank
you for taking the time to do this this
is very generous of you
so i'll just
welcome you back and then we will
be live okay awesome
all right so here we go
hot breath averse welcome back to the
hot breath podcast
the show where you learn comedy from the
pros today
we have a returning guest to help answer
all of your comedy questions she was a
guest
way back in hopper episode number 177
and now she is back today with our live
comic q a series welcome back to the hot
breath the verse the one and only
lunell everyone give it up for luna well
what episode
what episode is this we're in the 200s
now
since quarantine we stopped counting and
we've just been doing live q and a's
so we're in the 200s though okay well
thank you for having me back thanks for
doing this you know one of
your first episode with us was so well
received because you were so
focused on like comics appreciating the
craft appreciating
like the actual art behind stand-up and
not just trying to rely on like
quick success but to really appreciate
the craft and that really stuck with a
lot of people
oh i'm glad to hear that now just
just thinking off the top with um what's
currently happening it seems like
um comics are all we're all trying to
figure out
like what to do right now in terms of
like
how we can stay connected with our fans
or how we can even just
stay afloat for a lot of comics um what
if
what have you been doing in this time to
really try to
maximize without just just sulking i
guess
of what we don't have but focus on what
you do have
well i have taken this time to
get some well needed rest and i
did not have doing six shows a week for
years and years and years in a row i
also have been trying to
uh with the wake of the corona um
you know do more vitamins and do better
than we do on the road eating in the
airport eating on a plane
eating in the car stuff like that so
i've had a chance to do that
i've also of course like most people
been getting some things done around the
house
then you've wanted done for years that
were not able to be done because
only home two days a week and all that
kind of stuff
and i also have
just um been able to catch my breath you
know it's very
difficult being a mother and being on
the road and it's definitely taken
its toll on my relationship with my
daughter
and things like that so i've been trying
to
deal with some of that and
just being a little more appreciative of
my
home because you can have a home but if
you're never home to enjoy it
you know you you just have a place to
change your clothes
so um yeah i've been doing that some of
that
how many years would you say you've been
doing six shows a week that sounds
insane
oh probably uh
for the last like maybe five years
wow yeah and you you're having a vegas
residency recently too right
yeah i was doing shows before the six
shows a week
but once i got with you know this great
agency and they're like if you want to
work we'll work you
and then there you go and you start
trying to stack your money
which you know i'm no i'm no eddie
murphy or
wanda sykes but i've been able to
because of my hard work been able to sit
here for a couple of months
and not be thrown out on the street i
don't know how many more months i'll be
able to do that but
um you know i figure if it gets really
tight i i can always get a fans only
page or
busting open on a point hub or something
like that to be a couple of takers
um um
i i yeah i've been i've been on the road
like i forgot the question but i think
for the last five years doing six shows
a week the residency in las vegas
was gratefully at the jimmy kimmel
comedy club
which is in the promenade by the link
hotel
and the thing that makes that so great
because i had a little mini
residence here run at the sls hotel and
casino
prior to the jimmy kimmel uh residency
and the one at the sls they had uh eddie
griffin on monday tuesday wednesday
they had monique on thursday friday
saturday and i did sunday at 7.
at kimmel's i only do sunday nights at
10 o'clock it's a little way
you know more adult type show because it
doesn't start till 10 and it's on a
sunday
obviously every time they can harry
can't come because they have to be at
work on monday
and some people leave vegas on sunday
but those people who have
monday and tuesday's house in their job
and they're coming in and they want to
get it in too
so also the fact that jimmy kimmel's
comedy club is the only comedy club
with the national television show
connected to it so i was able to do his
television show
yeah and have some really great pictures
and
had a wonderful experience doing that so
um out of all the comics in the world
that they could let have that slot for
me to have it
as unconventional as i am uh is really a
pleasure but it's not really about being
conventional
is about putting asses in the seats
that's all they care about
and they put their money into printing
your face on every magazine and
caesar's corporation and making an led
sign with your face on it you better put
some asses
in those seats and you better be
consistent because nobody wants to pay
you for your bad
day you know so yeah it seems your
career has really taken off since you
did hot breath last so
congratulations on that yes thank you
what would i do without you where would
i be
who would i need
and i saw you you were working with um
eddie murphy
on a new movie what was that like
working with eddie murphy
well there's two movies there's one
that's on netflix right now called
dolomite is my name
about the late rudy ray moore who
everybody didn't
know and now
they have an opportunity to and
quickly after that i was um asked to be
in asked to be in uh
or actually i was just casting i wasn't
even asked there's no question
but to do the uh coming to america
sequel coming to america the quest
and um with the fact that every actor in
hollywood wants to be in that movie
uh hollywood and beyond mars and
the universe um i'm very pleased to be
in two eddie murphy movies back to back
um i got in that movie because of the
relationship with craig brewer and i
guess eddie
as well craig brewer is the director of
dolomite is my name he also
did hustle and flow and um his
uh doing did coming to america the quest
so i auditioned seven times i had seven
callbacks for dolomite is my name
so needless to say craig and i got to
know each other very very well
during those uh you know it was like the
old school screen test and everything
with the
wigs and the clothes and i felt very
hollywood but um
when this came along and i asked craig
how did i
get so lucky to end up in here he was
like well now i know what you can do
and you know i i really enjoyed you
and uh so you know i wanted to put you
in here which is a lesson to
you know young comics or even some old
ones and the lesson is don't be a dick
because nobody wants to work with a dick
but if you're nice and you're pleasant
and you're on time and you know your
lines and
you speak to the caterers and you're
nice to everybody and people are happy
to see your name on the call sheet
you could probably work for those people
again but if you come in there
on some deeper [ __ ] you know that that
word gets around too so
yeah yeah and you've worked with i mean
you've worked adam sandler sasha baron
cohen
i mean my i mean every sandra bull like
dm
x bradley cooper lady gaga beyonce
yeah so like what um are you people at
that
level of like success like are you is
there like a commonality you're seeing
between these people that
that maybe could rub off on to us that
are watching this
no because everybody no i
i don't because everybody is different
i will say that uh well
maybe i mean i will say that like sandra
bullock
bradley cooper gaga
beyonce um
mike myers anthony lopaglia john
they they have what the one common
thread is that they're very nice they're
very amenable
they're nice to the actors they're nice
to the crew they're not like
you know lee daniels who i heard as a
[ __ ] screaming lunatic
and they're they're uh uh are working
for tarantino who is
in fact a screaming lunatic but they get
the job done but
they're those people are very very nice
and it makes you
like if you got any kind of daddy issues
or whatever it makes you really want to
do your best
because they were so nice it makes you
want to please them
and get the um get the um
what's the word i'm looking for get the
um not accolades and accept and get the
approval of these people and i think
that's what comics won any damn way
is approval and love i think that's one
of the reasons that we do it it's one of
the reasons i do
yeah and what was it like eddie murphy
did you have any
memorable stories of getting to work
with him
oh for sure oh
for sure
let me see if i can tell anyway
um well first of all in dolomite is my
name
i actually auditioned for you have you
seen the movie i haven't no
wow i'm tripping yeah
i sort of want to hang up right now i
don't really watch netflix though to be
honest so i'm
yeah we're talking about eddie murphy
you're you are right
you're right yes jesus christ
how you even speak his name and you're
not up on his last two movies
after a comeback after not being on
[ __ ] film for like 20 [ __ ] years
now i just look like i'm trying to
appropriate his name now she's like
white boy just saying eddie murphy's
name
just for the come-up whiteboard turning
red is a strawberry
okay um well in the movie dolomite is my
name
i actually auditioned seven times for
the part
of queen b uh lady reid who was his
who was dolomites like homegirl best
friend
cohort you know but i didn't get that
part they gave that part to an actress
by the name of divine joy randolph
who i really really appreciate and i'm
glad she got that part
because i got to play the part of
eddie's aunt of a rudy's aunt
who gave him the seed money to start his
um
own uh record company so to speak
and that meant that the scene was just
eddie
and i it wasn't in a group i didn't have
other actors it was just
eddie and i at the kitchen table
and he hugged on me and jumped on me and
kissed on me and stuff like that after i
gave him the money
or or after he thought he convinced me
to get the money
and so that was very minimal memorable
because
who doesn't want that now i want to
preface all this by saying
i did not meet eddie on the set i
already knew eddie murphy we already had
taken pictures together we'd already
been in
the club and parties together plus i was
very good friends
with his late brother charlie murphy and
we had made a movie together and we had
done something
so eddie was very familiar with who i
was i'm very familiar with anyway
had i not been introduced to him
many years prior i might would have
geeked totally the [ __ ] out
[ __ ] up my lines lost it sweated
farted
everything like that but i didn't do
that because i already
knew him i was just very honored to be
working with him because after seeing
boomerang and after seeing
uh norbert and after seeing uh harlem
nights and everything you don't dream in
your wildest dreams that you'll ever
really be
working with eddie and that you'll go
down in history on film with them and
not one but two movies
so you know i was very glad that it
worked out the way that it did you know
yeah that's just one story i got some
other [ __ ] that is so crazy i can't even
really tell you
but yes i've got stories with eddie for
sure
wait the story's on set or this happened
off the set
on set and off oh
oh that's fun well i i uh i shot
a pilot back in the day when uh charlie
murphy
was on the show and he just he would
have a story like he was just like the
best storyteller i've ever met it was
just incredible
i mean that's why uh
charlie murphy true hollywood stories on
the chapelle show
was so popular because charlie can tell
these damn story joe and
just the way he told him just be like oh
my god charlie please stop
like stop so yeah i really miss him he
was
yeah a great guy yeah they would come
out of nowhere like he could segue
into like a five minute story off you
sneezing or something he's like that
reminds me
yes yes yes yes yes yes yes
oh that's so cool um
so let's uh let's get into some of these
young comic questions as well
uh and um i meant to ask you did you
watch the
the new dave chappelle special yet
i'm black uh i didn't know i i figured
it was required viewing but
you probably got the email you probably
have seen that years ago that probably
you guys got the early release of it
yeah if you're black you sent out a memo
to
all of us that he was writing at first
yeah
yeah i saw it yeah so what uh what was
your
what was your uh take on it how'd you
like what yeah it's just
it just blew my mind well um
i have a whole scenario i've turned that
whole thing into a bit
so you know about how his community must
have
been so excited to go see dave in the
park
you know so tired of all this black
lives matter
this is great we'll go see dave in the
park
bob grab a bottle of chardonnay let's go
see dave our neighbor dave
and then everybody got bit slapped you
could have heard a
rat piss on cotton out there it wasn't
[ __ ] funny
it was facts and it was you know now i'm
not a big fan of the n-word
you know but that's gay but i don't use
it in my show
unless i'm with my people i don't use it
in a mixed company because i don't want
anybody to get the idea that it's cool
or any [ __ ] like that
so i don't use it and i you know um
uh don't let anybody who's opening or
featuring for me
use it if they do then they're fired off
my shelf and that's
it's not even negotiable but for dave i
mean people know who they was going to
see
just like they knew who they was going
to see but when they go see richard
pryor
or they knew who they were going to go
see when they went to go see dick
gregory
or or anything like that so they knew
who they went to see
so you know that's not my flavor but it
certainly was impactive i'll tell you
yeah captivating yeah
i don't know if that's the word yeah
maybe that is the word oh i'm sorry oh
lord
mercy i'm sorry can the people see us
yeah they can definitely see us yep oh
let me also
uh uh apologize for my appearance
normally i'm much more glamorous than
this with lashes and the whole thing
but i just literally i just didn't
[ __ ] feel like it this morning you
know
i have on a little lip gloss i got a
little product in my little curly hair
and that's the best i could do so for
anybody who wants to have a snarky
comment about me looking like a turtle
or anything like that
[ __ ] you i didn't [ __ ] feel like it
so that's it you look beautiful lunell
i know right and and no one's yeah this
this this community is not about
roasting or making people feel bad this
is all about oh
you don't have any if you have anybody
in here
under 25 years old there absolutely
about that
you may not see it but i know better
they forget about anything you're saying
because they say she looks like you know
a ninja turtle she looked like miss
pochetta here
and and that will be the conversation
for the next like five you know
posts and stuff like that i know these
little bastards i think they do
well yeah you're going heavy on youtube
now the youtube comments are
insane but that seems to be like your
new strategy for quarantine is like
you're really doubling down on youtube
you know i didn't even consider it
until my friend flame monroe whose um
transgender uh comic flame was like girl
you know you gotta be doing youtube
because you got enough people on your
instagram
and so and flames my friend been my
friend for 20 years
and so i i said i always teach flame to
say
you're you're you're a lady with the
biggest dick i've ever seen in my life
but anyway um um uh so when
flames suggested to me that i'd do a
youtube show
i said well i could try you know i
started off on the couch and then we
went to the dining room and we had my
little set
and everything like this then the next
week we got a mixing board and the next
week we got a microphone and the next
week we got the
music and the week after that we had
playlists and da da da da da
and we started doing many shows instead
of fulfilling
episodes that we throw in there to keep
you teased so you don't have to wait
from
wednesday to wednesday then we got
monetized and we got commercials so you
know
i'm hoping that you know i wasn't going
in this with any
high hopes but i'm hoping that i could
be a big star like you one day and get
my
own show show or you know maybe go to
hbo and netflix or something like that
because i certainly have
uh gotten like over 22 000 subscribers
in the last like month and that's only
you know that's not even a third of the
instagram people that i have but
if anybody from my instagram at lumel
l-u-e-n-e-l-l would come over to my
youtube channel
hey now h-e-y-l-u-e-n-e-l-l
could be greatly appreciated and i might
get somebody's attention
but i'm enjoying doing it um i get super
glammed up
i even like take a bath and put on
perfume even though you can't
smell it but it just makes me feel like
i'm going
you know to the stage or whatever which
i always that's part of my ritual
and um so i've been having good success
with it and
we go every wednesday from 3 to 4 p.m
california time
and this next week we're going to do
that show and do our first
club quarantine vip lounge backyard
boogie meaning that we're gonna do
another show at night time from seven to
nine with special guests like
miguel nunez and laura hayes and red
grant and stuff like that
and we're gonna do it outside in the
backyard and have drinks and edibles
and um a dj and it's gonna be only like
seven or ten of us
that sounds fun yeah we're all getting
creative
don't you i know you want to go you can
invite me i'll probably i'll scare
people they'll think i'm 12 or something
well the aj and the police are some
people that could be a turnout
[Laughter]
did you see you know did you see
epstein's
uh thing yeah well that could be oh you
didn't see epstein's
document called filthy rich filthy wish
okay
no i didn't i heard it i didn't see it
yeah yeah
so well that's what i'm saying could be
a turnover somebody you looking 12.
all right let's let's get to a few young
comic questions here
let's go let's go it's um so one you
were talking about traveling a lot
so for uh comics do you have any travel
tips
yeah lots like try to
even before the virus i was like try to
take your own
food as much as you can a little
sandwich little
bagel little you know cheese and
crackers or even
cup of noodle you know um
because uh you never know when you're
gonna get delayed
on a plane and when you're delayed they
will not serve you
always buy a bottle of water when you
get through security
always never get on a plane without
snacks and water
ever because you never know when you
might get delayed and then also
you'll have that in your hotel room late
at night
snack when there's no room service or
you don't feel like going downstairs
then you always have a little snack
apples oranges
things like that are always good to
travel with i think
awesome all right and that was michelle
by the way michelle van duzens thanks
for asking michelle
hey michelle oh it's uh
bob jorgensen asks could you describe
for us your writing process
well i'm weird in as much as i really
don't write
because i'm not a scripted comic i'm
more off the cuff
i have what they call the gift i can't i
can't
describe it any other way i can write
bullet
points down and say oh i need to talk
about this i need to talk about that
like you know i i i write you know i
need to talk about prince harry and
megan bro
i know what i want to say about that i
want to talk about dave chappelle's
special boom i know what i want to say
about that
and i have the gift of gab no two shows
that i do are exactly the same
and i don't want to be if i'm going to
memorize the script i'm going to get
more money than i do
to do stand-up you know that would be
for a film or something like that
and um i don't want to tax my brain
because
sometimes the scripted comic will be
thrown off by a heckler or by something
else
and then they got to try to get back
where they were in their scripted mind
and it could be a [ __ ] show so i just uh
i just write bullet points i don't
really write
oh nice and it do you record your set
and then review it or do you all
you just remember it every time you go
on stage type deal no i try not to
listen to it actually
because um number one i don't like my
speaking voice i
always sound to me like i've got a glob
of you know mashed potatoes in my throat
or something
and then also if i look and see what i
did
which may have been outrageous i might
get embarrassed and not do it again
and i think the magic of my show is that
you never know what the hell i'm going
to do or say
and i don't want to get like oh i don't
want to do that again look what i looked
oh my god they could see my stomach
i don't want to do that so i don't i
really unless it's for a special or
something
i really really look at my [ __ ] again
hmm
all right coming up next john
chappelle he asks uh
what are the experiences from the first
five to ten years of your career that
were most memorable and you feel
impacted
your path to where you are today
well i think within the first
i think within the first 10 years of my
career
black people got to be on national
television war doing comedy because
within the first 10 years of my career
uh comic view and death jam were created
and that brought you out of the clubs
and on television which will get you
more
dates and more money in the clubs
because you've not been on television
make your celebrity
so i think it would have to be going
mainstream on television
hmm were there any early
like doubts or like hurdles you had to
overcome just from
like oh the ups and downs of being a
comedian
well of course because before i'm a
comedian i'm a mother
and i worked on i was i was in makeup
when i went into labor
i worked every day up until the day i
had my child
and i was in clubs and everything like
that i wasn't traveling as much
but i was locally like the it girl i was
doing like
four or five clubs a week in oakland
california
and then once i had my child
um you know
i still was working uh in in
oakland in the bay area and sometimes i
would have to take my baby
with me in the car seat and hire on
stage
sometime i would have to burp her on
stage
with the baby on my shoulder and the
microphone and this other hand
my daughter's father was a comedian as
well at that time
he's retired now comedians don't really
retire
they die but he retired because he
sort of he didn't he didn't move with
the times with his material
and he started to fade out and so he
just got a regular job
and was taking help take care of the
kids so sometimes i would have to have
her on my shoulder
and pass her out to him he would come to
the club pick her up you know um
it was very hard to fly away and leave
your child if they have the whooping
cough or something like that
especially being the mother you want to
make sure they got rubbed on with this
you want to make sure the covers are on
them
and it's been it's been very very
difficult very very stressful
i'm proud to say now uh that my daughter
is 24 years old very independent
and just gave me a whole bunch of [ __ ]
yesterday about not being around when
she was growing up
so they're going to grow up and throw it
back in your [ __ ] face when they get
older as much as you try to do the right
thing
you know so that's always hard for a
mother
uh wanting a mother or a wife in this
business
all right that's good advice oh and that
um
a comic actually asked the cedric drake
i think he's from the bay area he asked
uh
how much being from the bay area has
shaped your comedy
oh being from the bay area has shaped
everything in my life
first of all um especially now
while growing up in oakland i grew up
during the black panther movement
and so i'm very you know much the
activist in my heart
very uh aware of
my surroundings i grew up in oakland but
i was educated in the suburbs in castro
valley california
and i moved back to oakland castro
valley is a 99
white community my parents were doing
pretty good my mother was a nurse my
father was a
supervisor and they had our house built
well the white folks out there resented
that
and we got egged and tomatoes and all
this kind of stuff
so also being from the bay area i had
a opportunity to be on television
every day before i really left oakland
and there was a
station at all uh black owned and
operated station just like the et
was um it was called sobe television
network
and i was a vj and i was a talk show
host and i was a
you know cook and da da
and i used to bring my kid on tv with me
you know because she was small still as
well and
i had different hours and everything so
i would do the club
maybe from 9 to 11 go to the studio
do my television show from midnight to
4am sleep at the studio
uh because the lady acquit and come back
on the air from seven until 11 a.m
and then go home gosh
yeah uh every day i'm hustling yeah i
was about to say you straight up
hustler yeah i got i'm like
i'm like a machine i like a racehorse i
love it you know
oh my god you know what they do to
racehorses though
turn them into glue they shoot them [ __ ]
put them at the bastard that's very
inspiring though just to like see
someone at your success level but
knowing hey
none of this is without hard work for
several years
and then i want to talk about my success
level my success level is
nothing like i'm very popular
but i'm not rich you know monique came
out
about that whole thing about black women
not getting paid
in uh the business and you know maybe
her delivery rubbed over the people the
wrong way
but the facts that she was talking about
very very true
you know black female comics
don't get sponsorships like male
comics do you know kevin hart is
was selling denali's hell he needs a
step stool to get in the [ __ ]
but i'm a woman and i have kids and
groceries
and i feel like i could sell a denali as
well as anybody
you know you got cedric hawkins stuff
you got
all these guys hawking things that you
don't see any women
with sponsorship deals i've never had a
show of my home
i've always been a guest on everybody
else's show every time
and i've shot seven pilots chappelle
shot 13
before he got to chappelle's show so
i'll shot seven pilots of my own
it gets up here and then something
happens gets up here and then somebody
say no
gets up here you get a pandemic yes so
you know so
i'm very much in the community i don't
live behind a gated
community you know i live um two blocks
away from
the marathon shop where nipsey hustle
got murdered at
i um you know in the heart of the black
lives matter movement in the crenshaw
district
you know um i uh have nothing but
african-americans and uh latinos on my
street i think we got an italian
guy across the street but i think he
works for the mob and then so
um i uh he's very very secret too
and and so you know i've i've done it
you know i don't have to
integrate myself into the suburbs i was
raised
in the suburb i'm not a black girl who
lived in the hood and made my way out
i'm a sister who was raised in the burbs
and came back to the
hood and hood doesn't mean ghetto hood
means neighborhood
so i live in a neighborhood of very you
know
diverse people and and and i appreciate
it because
there is a freedom to being
around minorities and i'm going to tell
you
people keep trying to move away move
away i want to move up to the right i
want to get a house in here
because you're trying to move away from
the minorities and you think you'll have
a better life and you will have a
more beautiful home and i don't know
because now you've got the homeowners
association
tipping around your house telling you
the [ __ ] weeds are eight inches too
high
or you got a neighbor who's calling the
police on you because you're in your own
million dollar backyard
having fun at your own pool party but
they're disturbed
by the music which ain't rap music it
could be soul music motown music
you know down here the
the mexicans on the corner they have a
fiesta every [ __ ] friday
but if they're playing music they're not
banging they're playing music and i like
live music
why would i call the police on them if i
want to have a fish fry or like i said
my backyard wicked it's only going to be
two hours long
uh next wednesday night you know i don't
have to worry about the police
coming here because somebody called them
because i'm disturbing them
we're just very chill we very much mind
our business very much like
what's the big deal we don't do that
it's i don't know about these
uptight fight folks that always want to
make their business to patrol
[ __ ] you know and um
that i'm really having a problem with
really having a problem with it
but when it comes to being uh a black
female comedian i mean is there
you've been doing comedy over 30 years
is there like a resentment or do you see
what needs to be changed or like how to
change it like
well as far as the i don't think there's
a resentment because you know
i mean i continue to work like people
like to work with me yeah i love to work
i love my job i love to go on set
i i've only ever wanted to be one thing
and that was an entertainer i never had
a plan b
i never um you know thought about
anything else i had thought about being
a teacher
and then i got a load of these [ __ ]
kids and i was like well that's out
and um you know i i grew up watching
you know doris gay and gene kelly and
that's entertainment and all that stuff
and the glamour and you know the
supremes and
all the foo-foo stuff and that just got
in my blood and i said oh i want to do
that that's what i want to do
and i've never wanted to do anything
else and i pursued that
viciously and i have achieved that but
as far as making
big big money like you know let's take a
star is born
i'm in the movie a stars one there's
four comics in the movie a star is born
dave chappelle eddie griffin myself and
andrew dice clay
um one of the biggest movies ever i
nominated for academy award
but hell i'm not gaga i'm not bradley i
wasn't the main person i was just a
regular hired actor
i didn't make scale but i made a little
bit above that but you get paid once and
you don't get paid no more
until the residuals come around and
you'll make that for the rest of your
life but as the movie
dwindles in fame the residuals get
smaller you see
and i have the the blessing is i do get
a lot of mailbox money because i've done
so many films and television product
projects that every 90 days is like
check check check check check
but those checks range from like three
thousand dollars which i'm still getting
for borat
down to maybe 12 cents for something
that i did like nash bridges or
something like that
so you know and then if you don't work
you don't there's no retirement plan for
comics
there's no health plan for comics if you
don't go into acting
you can't you know it's just you know
you get to be in a union comics don't
have a union
we're the only entertainers that don't
have one even a clown
has a union but we don't have one
so if a club owner does this
wrong we literally have to take it to
the streets because there's nobody to go
[ __ ] to about there's nobody to protect
you
and as a woman it makes you very hard
because you got to play with the big
boys out here in these streets
and you can't be no punk and you got to
stand up for what you know is right and
you gotta demand your respect and demand
this and that
and all that kind of stuff yeah that's
uh justin williams that actually asked
that like
if if a booker or promoter doesn't pay
you
what they said they're going to like how
do you deal with that
well you have to find them and
threaten them that's what you do
okay or or and you really or you have to
whip their ass or get dance
that's what you do because there is
nowhere to complain who are you going to
talk to
the police give a [ __ ] there's no
there's nobody to protect the comic
we're like dope dealers we're like the
last gangsters of entertainment
and that's the truth
i mean it really is do i look like i'm
naked i have on some clothes i want to
look like
do i look like i'm naked you show it
you're showing a lot of skin
[Laughter]
i got all gussied up for this look i got
a button down on i was ready for this
i can smell you don't you have on some
old spice or some [ __ ] like that
got on oh
okay hi karate do you even know anything
about high karate
i don't know anything about hi karate
right now before your time that wasn't
i can't even go into it that was a
cologne i swear ask somebody over 50
about high karate they'll fall out on
the floor
oh that was back in the am radio days i
see okay
you don't don't [ __ ] hate on am radio
there's a lot of gangster [ __ ] going on
there
they think everybody's gone but
everybody that guy
so let's um let's land this plane here
um cause i know your time is extremely
valuable we appreciate you doing this um
just oh but no no no glad to let me do
two more questions
all right we'll do two more how breath
the verse we got two more out of lunell
she's having fun
so do you know that hot breath is the
most offensive
thing like if you're dancing with a guy
and his hot
breath is breathing down your neck i was
like because when i heard the name of
the podcast i'm not going to tell you
this before
i was like hot breath good lord who
wants
that but um but you remember it for you
you remember it yes
uh patrick simon asks uh well first off
there's a lot of people thanking you for
doing this
saying thanks for doing this they're
giving applause emojis like people are
very grateful for this
oh that's great so follow me on
instagram and
and and subscribe to my youtube
subscribers
right there that you yeah youtube is the
move yeah subscribe to her
youtube and follow her on instagram but
like yeah and say that you heard about
me on hot breath i'll write you back
yes let her know you heard her on here
hop brother and sister
yeah so
uh patrick simon asks and a few people
were curious
about like you're acting and things like
that
and that whole side of your career but
he asks did you
did your stand-up lead to your career in
films or did you pursue them
separately
actually
my acting career came first
believe it or not because i um
i started off in theater actually which
is the advice and i give
people like how do i get in a minute i'm
like start
you know slow start in theater see can
you memorize
lines see do you read well aloud
see what your comprehension is see can
you take constructive criticism
and direction without getting all in
your feelings
and see can you work with other people
because that's what you have to do in
order to make movies and work on
television
and if you want to start awful sorry
it's garbage day here in the hood
my garbage man he's tearing [ __ ] up out
there okay
um see here we go
um but theater is where i
i started and and i was in the bay
and i was uh the first movie i did was
so i married an ex-murderer
with mike myers and anthony lepaglia
and all that and uh that was under san
francisco i wasn't even in the union yet
because that was my first thing
so when you see it i wasn't even blonde
yet when you see it the voice coming out
of my mouth is not my voice
because when they had to do od adr
uh the overdubs you know later
they didn't have to call me because i
wasn't in the union the movie that got
me in
the union was my second film which was
the rock with sean connery and nicholas
cave
and i was seven months pregnant when i
did that
on alcatraz in the middle of the night
you know i must have killed that because
they wanted somebody who could improvise
they had to shoot the next they had to
shoot on monday this was a thursday
and they wanted somebody that they
didn't have to write for just for a
little part
i mean for somebody to get hired several
months pregnant
they either they either they either
thought i was fat i wish i'm a little
chubby
or they just didn't pay any attention or
i disguised it well with my
oversized adidas track suit but um
uh that when i got cast in the rock
i was on a thursday i had until monday
to join the union and to join the union
at that time was 1086.53
back in 1995 and so i went to three club
owners in oakland jeffrey from jeffrey's
inner circle
jimmy from sweet jimmy's and chuck
johnson from the sobe television network
and i got like 500 from each and we ran
across them the summons at the bay
bridge and
got into san francisco and got to the
psych office on friday at 4
45 because they said if i did not join
sag by
friday i would not be able to step on
the set on monday
so anyway i had done those two films
before i ever
moved to la and la is actually where my
comedy career started
but i ended up moving back to oakland
and that's where my comedy career
uh marinated and got seasoned
and have a lot of acting gigs come from
people knowing your stand up or are they
still kind of mutually exclusive worlds
say that again because you cut out for
just a minute can you ask me that yeah
has a lot of your acting work come from
people
knowing your standup comedy or more from
knowing your acting
a lot of gigs have come from
them knowing my standup uh reputation
because when you're a good stand-up and
they hire you
they're hiring you because they know
that whatever they have written on paper
you're going to be able to bring more to
it in every single take
or they know that they don't really have
to write for you
they can just tell you the bullet points
they want you to hit and if you're
intelligent you have acting jobs you can
weave the fabric and be the thread
through the fabric of the
of the piece and get to those bullet
points and get there in a comedic way
but not
going too over the top you know so i
would say that
a lot of my uh
film and television credits have come
from my
my acting shops but of course i have to
audition for stuff
too you know which i hate well you did
you said seven auditions for dolomite
right
yeah but i really wanted that
[ __ ] boy yeah yeah
i understand eddie [ __ ] yeah eddie i'd
have done that i did
you know i'd have done anything anything
[Laughter]
so the final one and i think this is a
great way to wrap it up
on this show um dennis thule asks
what is the best piece of advice someone
gave you for comedy
the best piece of advice i ever got
was from one of the queens of comedy
miss laura hayes
she was also a staple on comic view for
many many years
she played martin's mother i mean cole's
mother on
martin and she's also from oakland
california
this is going to sound crazy but i'll
explain why the best piece of advice
i ever ever got was shut the [ __ ]
up and listen that was the best
advice i got be in comics we talk for a
living
and we're always running our mouth but
you will learn more if you just shut up
like get around some you know the comic
circles like you do comedy and then
at the end of the night everybody goes
for a drink or whatever like that just
you know
don't feel like you have to rebuttal
[ __ ] don't feel like you have to
add to the conversation shut the [ __ ] up
and listen
listen and you will learn so much
because obviously if you're in a
uh circle with some og's there you
definitely don't know as much as they
are
and even if you disagree a thing you
don't always have to verbalize that
so the best and it was hard for me and i
did i didn't do it right at first
but you know shut the [ __ ] up and listen
the best advice that i
i got and that i can give
i hear you loud and clear on that that's
that's the whole thing of this show is
just like getting to connect with comics
like you
and just just listen and absorb like
it's it's
it's priceless thank you so much lunell
you're very welcome i just want to say
once again
um if you guys would be so kind as to
follow me on my instagram that's at lou
now
at l-u-e-n-e-l-l tell me that you heard
me on
hot press are subscribed to my youtube
channel which if you go to instagram you
can just click the link in the bio and
take you straight over there
it's called hey now h-e-y-l-u-e-n-e-l-l
i want to thank you for having me on
again and actually changed my
mood from what it was before i got on
here because i just been you know
so inundated with cnn and this and that
and
this on instagram and that on instagram
just a steady diet of
it's just a steady diet of like
hate right now and you know comedy is
the relief like i have
every expectation that one of the
busiest places one of the hottest places
to get into one of the most packed
places
that we're going to have when the
pandemic is
under control will be the comedy clubs
because
people come to comedy clubs to escape
they come it's like taking an e-fil
that i don't know anything about that
but i heard and it's like
going to the top you know you go to a
common club to relax and to release and
have an adult beverage and throw your
head back and listen to stuff
even if it's political if it's funny you
know nobody want to get preached at
after all this you know you want to have
some place to release yourself i found
myself on my youtube show
you know getting kind of deep and i had
to sort of like pull myself back
not that you can't get deep but you have
to pull yourself back because they are
looking to you
for escape they are looking to you for
release and relaxation and that's what
that's what our job is his comics all
right well comics
you've heard it from the legend herself
lunell
we're so excited to have you back on hot
breath go subscribe
and follow her i will be sure to put the
links in the show notes and on our
youtube
videos so people go support thank you
and thank you
it's it's it's an honor to have you on
here for the second time honestly thank
you so much
i just want to let you know i appreciate
your little but appreciate your little
button down
and that you look real cute this morning
and you
you know if we ever see each other one
day and throw back a couple of drinks
you know you could probably get it
i wouldn't embarrass myself like that i
would not even
no no i'm not ruining my reputation in
this game
well i have a wife as well but you know
besides that still i don't wanna
i don't care she'd probably set me up
with it she'd be like yeah go
go ruin your reputation yeah i couldn't
handle it i wouldn't knock any gristle
off i know who you are with the gristle
i wouldn't oh my gosh
hilarious have a great day thanks for
sharing
thank you so much of course have a great
day i'm glad we could boost your mood
have a good day
thanks a lot bye everybody out there
i'll see you on my youtube channel
yes hey lunell that's right baby thank
you
thank you bye if you're serious about
becoming a comedian
join our facebook group linked in the
description below to start getting tips
like these every single day
and watch this playlist of our top
writing tips to improve your writing
[Music]
today